my name is Christine Collins a March
10th my nine-year-old son Walter Collins
disappeared the five-month investigation
led to a boy being brought to Los
Angeles from DeKalb Illinois the LAPD
told me and all of you that this boy was
my son he was not my son
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey it's episode 58 yeah what's this one
about
this one is actually we're doing a
true-crime twofer yeah actually we
decided to do this well I decided to do
this
yeah frankly even tell me about these
cases yeah we decided to do this because
one true crime is like probably my
favorite set of topics that we do on
this show and since this show is going
up on my birthday
the 10:06 then I thought I would
celebrate in that way and also because
my new true crime book the faceless
villain is officially finished done and
will soon be available for sale at least
the print in the e-book and then the
audiobook will probably be up a week or
two later right so I wanted to do a true
another true crime show now both of
these cases were requests from two
different people they're not in the new
book are they no because these were
actually solved they know who did these
because my book is all unsolved murders
and but these ones were solved they know
who did them so but they have like a lot
of really creepy details and like I said
you know both of these were requests by
two separate people the first one is
gonna be the corpse wood Manor murders
version never heard of it yeah and the
second one is the wine bill chicken coop
murders okay from California and that
was from the 1920s all right so we're
gonna be talking about both of those and
before we do that let's do our regular
shout outs our regular stuff at the
beginning of the show like I said my new
book the faceless villain will be out
very very soon I just finished doing the
print layout and everything like that so
all I have to do now I think I just have
to do like a blurb for the back cover
and just get it all uploaded yeah it's a
big book - that's the size of the unseen
hand yeah it's about the same I think
it's only like 40 pages less or
something like that but yeah it should
be should be good there's a lot of
really good stuff in there it's all
unsolved murders from 1900 to 1959 its
vol 1 there's eventually gonna be three
volumes I'm hoping that it's gonna be a
popular book I think I think the
unsolved unsolved murders I think that I
think there's a big following for that
yeah I mean I'm fascinated by that kind
of stuff yeah you know what I mean and I
know a lot of other people are too
because you know what I was doing the
research for the book and everything it
does seem like there's a lot of
information about a lot of these because
a lot of people are really interested in
these cases and so you know I picked
ones that were famous but I try to find
some ones that were not so famous - yeah
I'm interested to see what happens you
know it's unsolved miss is unsolved
murders more popular than paranormal I
would kind of think I think it's like a
broader we'll see how about you know
we'll see how it goes but yeah so that
should be out really soon if you look
out for that in a week or two it should
be up also we just put up a new movie
review right we did Flash Gordon yeah we
did Flash Gordon yeah so that's up if
you didn't see it and we'll put another
one up a couple days from now oh okay
we're gonna do come I got something
special planned for Conan he's been
talking about this he just got the
blu-ray and he's been talking about his
I've been studying his theories behind
the movie for a couple of days there's a
lot more there than I remembered
when I was a kid yeah yeah now coming
out of the army and knowing you know for
German philosophy and some of the West
some of the Eastern philosophies you
know like Friedrich Nietzsche and Arthur
scope and power and mythos ISM that's
helping me understand what Conan was
that it's a much deeper movie than I
remembered yeah the directors awesome
Ellis
he loves soldiers and warrior culture
and he's a warrior worshiper a big part
of this book is hero worship or movie is
hero worship yeah like I haven't woken
my minds rusty I guess oh yeah well yeah
so that'll be the next one will be
coating the Barbarian and that should be
up a few days from now probably Friday
or Saturday right and also don't forget
about our patreon page thank you to our
newest patron Matt thank you very much
for your support
yeah and also we I'm thinking about
doing a google hangout on September 30th
which is this coming
today for our $10 and up patrons so if
any of you guys are the $10 nut patrons
and you have any suggestions about like
what time you would prefer even if you
want to do it on Sunday that's fine too
I don't really care you know let me know
I'll send out some invitations probably
later in the week yeah for people who
want to do it and stuff like we tried to
do one last month and then like no one
showed up and then like one person
showed up but it was artists too late
yeah that was like 30 or 40 minutes in
and we were already kind of like crap
[Music]
yeah I'm sure I'm sure our patreon
activity will get a little more you know
intense once we have more how many do we
have maybe yeah although we're close
we're close we're closing on it yeah yes
that weights being carried by four but
yeah so if any of you guys want to do a
google hangout pretend that we're not
patron then I'm thinking about Saturday
so like Saturday afternoon or something
like that yeah but you know we'll see
how that goes
okay now also halloween is coming up
next month our favorite holiday of the
year
now I think it was John R who is one of
our youtube listeners yeah
and I mentioned yeah and yeah he always
leaves us like such awesome comments
like he just writes these big long
comments no awesome comes with a good
ideas yeah and he's come up with like a
lot of oh yes and I was trying to think
I think I mentioned on one show a while
back that I was like oh I wanted to do
something special for the Halloween show
because the show was gonna go because I
think Halloween's on a Tuesday this year
so the show is actually gonna go up on
Halloween like the day of Halloween and
I was like so we should do a Halloween
special what should I do like what
should we do and I couldn't think of
anything and I think it was John our
that came up was like hey why don't you
do like reader ghost stories you like
yeah have you contribute and I'm like
man that's an awesome idea okay
so if you guys have like a good true
ghost story it has to be true mm-hmm
that happened to you or happened to
someone in your family or something
like that then I want you guys to
contribute them and I can read the best
ones on the show where do they contact
well they can actually you can either
contact me on YouTube and I'll give you
my email or I can just give the email
right now I'll put the email in the link
to the description on YouTube too and
I'll put it in the link to the
description on that audio thing you can
actually send them to my email which is
grave cake at gmail.com and so if you
want to write out a true ghost story
that happen to you and we'll pick the
best one so like if we have a lot and we
can't draw longer but we'll pick the
best ones and we'll put the mother I
just wanted to get like out ahead of
time so so it's any kind of ghost story
any kind of paranormal story yeah it's
kind of maybe weird or creepy right you
can you can say yeah it doesn't actually
yeah it doesn't necessarily it's just me
like a creepy story but it has to happen
to you or someone you know like it has
to be a true story can it be UFO story
yeah if it's creepy okay if it's creepy
okay that's the only criteria then it's
creepy or it has to be true it's like it
has to be like a personal experience all
right
and we and I wanted to you know give you
guys like a month out so you know we
could get ones and see though we might
have you honest guests yeah but yeah we
wanted to do that for our Halloween
special and you know show appreciation
for our listeners yeah so you know
thanks John our for that idea cuz that
was an awesome idea so that's what we're
gonna do hopefully we'll get some good
stories yeah we got a lot of good movies
that are gonna come up a review - I'm
sitting here looking at the list of them
oh man I'm gonna get every one of these
on blu-ray yeah how many million dollars
yeah that's like 50 or 60 runs yeah that
one's on the Omega Man the evil they
have blood yeah I definitely wanna do
some Mario Bava I want to do some Dario
Argento
David Lynch is a legacy favorite Oh
Bubba hotep yeah yeah so those are all
be upcoming like I said they'll take a
while to get to them all but we have a
big huge list okay so
anyway speaking of creepy let's get to
our true crime topics yeah tell us about
this okay now someone and I'm sorry I
can't remember who it was but someone
suggested I think it was on the Facebook
page that we do something about corpse
wood Manor now I had heard a corpse wood
Manor in the paranormal sense because I
know that like a lot of paranormal
groups there cuz it's supposed to be
haunted the blah-dee-blah
but I didn't really know the details of
what actually happened there right okay
so here is what happened in the 1970s
about 1976 1978 1979 teen 77 there's a
guy named dr. Charles Scudder and he was
a professor of psychopharmacology at
Loyola in Chicago now he was married he
had four kids and stuff like that but I
believe his wife died and he had always
had you know a male companion he had
been living as in their houses and as a
handyman or whatever now when dr.
Scudder turned 50 he decided he's like
well I'm sick of teaching I'm sick of
living in Chicago the rat race
everything like that so him and his
partner whose name is Joey
Odom decided you know let's go out in
the wilderness and we'll live off the
grid we're gonna we're gonna build a
house out there and we'll be totally
self-sufficient we'll be awesome which
we don't want to be in the city anymore
and stuff like that
basically they they did all this
research and stuff like that and they
found 40 acres out in this really really
remote part of Georgia by the
Appalachians and it was super cheap so
they go out there they buy 40 acres and
then they live in a trailer in the
property and they built just the two of
them built this huge brick house and
they called it corpse wood manners and
they named it that there any photographs
of this house yeah how does it look like
it's still there but it's you know it's
a ruin now obviously and some of its
going because I think there was a fire
but the brittle the brick part is still
there it's pretty much just like a
really big it's like two or three
stories and it's just this really big
brick structure with these arches and it
has this huge like winged gargoyle like
on the front of it cuz these two guys
they look cool yeah it's cool again I'm
sure it looks better
like back in the day now it's kind of
you know all overgrown and everything
but so they decide so they built this
house just the two of them not in the
middle of nowhere and you know it didn't
have that they had no electricity you
know they had their but but they had
their own well they grew all their own
food they had their own vineyard they
made their own wine huh and all this
other stuff so it's two gay guys living
out an off-the-grid yelling their own
mansion a brick okay now is this again
this was well they moved there and I
think the house was done in this 1977
okay all right so they move out there
now there's kind of a lot of controversy
about the case because now some people
from the area said well there were
rumors that they were Satanists that
they had like orgies out there and stuff
like that I don't really think I'd buy
that way guys they're living way out
there off the grid and they're gonna get
enough people to come right now and I
feel like one this is rural Georgia
these are two open gay guys Sam it's the
late 70s early 80s they're gonna make up
stories yeah people are gonna make up
stories about them because they're
eccentric right and now they don't I
don't really think they were Satanists I
mean people that knew Charles Scudder he
had joined the Church of Satan Anton
LaVey Church of Satan earlier because he
was curious about it but he wasn't like
a we've already done show we know what
that was he was just a theist basically
what you're talking about
- gay goth dudes prototype pretty much
in the seven and if you look like there
are pictures of the inside of their
house they had like uh they had like
this fireplace I think it was a
fireplace and of like a get-well face on
it's definitely got him like these guys
seemed rad
yeah right pretty entertaining yeah
they're probably fun now they also now
some people that actually visited them
or who lived in the area at the time
we're like no they were super friendly
you know they made their own why they
invited people over to their house
have they're wide and have parties and
stuff and dr. Scudder was since he was
into pharmacology he had some LSD that
was apparently pretty good so you know
you could go and party with them with
them with wine it's definitely right now
one thing they didn't do they had the
main house and then they also had like a
guest house that they called the chicken
coop which is weird because I didn't
even know we were gonna do a chicken
coop murders on the same show as this so
I was like wow that's a weird tie-in no
relation but I'm just saying so they had
this guest house it was three stories
and it was called the chicken coop and
that's where they had all their parties
and all their guests over and stuff like
that because apparently dr. Scudder
didn't want people in the main part of
the house which I don't you know I was
like he's private yeah that was like his
private boat so he didn't like so when
they had guests over they entertained
them in this big three-story guest house
and they had a room on top that was
called the pink room and basically they
owned their own Club pretty much yeah
right you know like I said they had
people over that's not a cool idea I
know yeah no nerds do that anyway well
they weren't millionaire see and that
was where some of the problem happened
because they were trying to live like
millionaires yeah yeah that's kind of
cool idea that it is yeah and like I
said and it's really and it sucks like
what happens it's like those guys that
go out in the woods and then just build
their own castle out of rocks that
they're finding right I'm like that's I
mean that's hardcore that he decided I
just don't even want to live in the city
I'm just gonna get it we're gonna build
our own house right they had to grew
their own food they didn't even need
money they don't have electricity they'd
have they're literally a medieval
fashion yeah I'm cool idea you know
fantasy probably not as fun to actually
do is no but apparently they had a good
time I mean living without electricity
yeah it was just two of them and they
had two big dogs that they loved you
know they've just kind of lived out
there and whatever yeah okay now because
they have 40 acres it was very common
for various locals to come and ask them
to hunt on their property right and so
they would allow that obviously sure and
so a lot of people knew who they were
and stuff like that okay now one of the
guys who wanted to hunt on their
property was this
bag named Avery Brock who he was only 17
I believe at the time yeah and he was
one of the people that asked for the
hunt on their land and he had hunted on
their land
hunted rabbits and various things okay
well Avery Brock being not terribly
bright there are rumors that one that he
tried to get in on like a threesome with
the two guys and either they they let
him and it was fine for they were like
no cuz you're young you know what I mean
there's you know there's no real nobody
knows what happened there or I might
have been the other way around the two
guys works invited him into a threesome
and he said no Seattle I don't really
think so because he went to their house
like all the time
alright so he was friends like and hung
out yeah-yeah so he had been there many
times he had been on their land many
times now because of the way they lived
he had the mistaken perception that they
had money falling out of their [ __ ]
pretty much yeah which was not true I
mean dr. Scudder he don't he'd have been
a professor his partner was you know
just kind of like a handyman type of guy
right I mean he had basically dr.
Scudder had basically sold everything he
owned to build this build this palace
out there the only money they had was he
had a little bit from a trust fund from
his dad which was only now I've heard
that it was only like $100 a month
vanna's which back in you know which
even in 1982 it wasn't like 250 bucks
now and nowadays so you know it went
further back then but not that much
further so basically they had sunk all
their money into this now he did have
some kind of valuable antiques and stuff
that he had bought over the years but
you know they weren't like wallowing in
money or anything like that but however
Avery brach thought they were so he
tells his other scumbag buddy
Tony West who was like his roommate they
lived on this trailer or whatever he's
like hey there are these two
quote-unquote queer devil worshippers
that live out in the woods and I go in
their house sometimes they drink their
wine and stuff and they have all this
[ __ ] money and we should go rob them
right right so this is what happens
it's December of 1982 and Avery and Tony
are at their friend's house and they hit
they had these two friends named Joey
Wells and Joey Wells girlfriend Teresa
Hudgens and they said hey we're gonna go
out to this corpse wood manner place in
the woods these two gay guys live out
there and they make their own wine and
they're awesome and you know party out
there so they were like okay fine so
they go out into the woods and they go
into the pink house the chicken coop now
there's a party going on there for
several hours you know they're all
drinking wine they're having a good time
now the teenagers they're on now I don't
think a stutter and Odom were doing any
drugs particularly but the teenagers
were on this drug that they called
toodaloo never know which they made it
it was alcohol glue and paint these type
of dudes so they were doing that and
they were hanging out with the guys for
several hours having a party whatever
and then Avery's like okay well I'm
gonna go out to the car and mix up some
more of our drugs right and I'll be back
in a minute so when he comes back from
the car he's got his hunting rifle hmm
now at first
Charles stutter I mean Avery has been
over at their house like all the time
they're like you know friends or
whatever so he just thought it was kind
of funny and he was kind of drunk too
and he was just go bang bang no I mean
why have your gun with you and stuff
like that yeah well so basically Avery
like just gives Tony West the gun then
he pulls a [ __ ] knife out of his boot
and puts the knife to dr. skutters neck
and says give me all the money right
right and scatters like I don't know
buddy
whatever now at this point the other two
kids who were there Joey Welles and
Teresa Hudgens who apparently had not
known that this was going to go down
right they tried to get the [ __ ] out of
Dodge they ran out of house now the car
wouldn't start
so they were like [ __ ] now what do we do
so then they go back into the room now
apparently Teresa tried to tell us don't
don't hurt anybody you know what I mean
she was kind of trying to stop it her so
she said and evidently that did not work
out now they told Joey Odom they send
him out of the house or they sent him
downstairs that's like the it's weird
because the the accounts are kind of
strange I'm not sure where everyone was
like during all this time so but the but
apparently Scudder and Odom were
separated now they went to too Joey Odom
and basically he just got up from hit
the couch or whatever and they just shot
him right in the face like four or five
times man and then shot their two dogs
that were just sleeping by the fireplace
or whatever yeah right so then they
Brock leads dr. Scudder who who was in
the pink house so he was separated from
his boyfriend and they lead him down
into the room and he and show him that
the guy's dead and the dogs are dead and
the guys like he yeah he was just like
horribly grief-stricken and couldn't
even say anything
and then basically Brock just puts the
gun up to his face and just shoots him
in the face he just shot his [ __ ]
face off yes now there is this is kind
of weird
evidently dr. Scudders last words before
he was shot in the face were I asked for
this damn witch okay
first of all the only people that were
there were the killers and the two
people that were with them right so I'm
not sure who it was that said that that
was what he said before he got shot it
kind of sounds to me like they made
something up like to make themselves
feel better
or make them sound less guilty or
something like that because what ended
up happening is that the two guys that
you know the two guys that did the
killing and I don't want to say because
I you know maybe not they might have got
away with the [ __ ] because their whole
defense was that well these two guys
were devil wars
furs and they were and they drugged us
and there was like a big orgy and [ __ ]
like that
and it was almost kind of like people in
the town we're kind of like yeah they
kind of had it coming you know I mean
they wanted there was that perception
that they wanted to believe this not
everybody believed that but a lot of
people did now some people argue that
the only reason that the two guys got
put in prison was because okay basically
after they killed the guys they stole
Scudders Jeep which was a black Jeep and
it had white Pentacles on the doors
right yeah like I said these guys
sounded awesome
I'm like I don't sell them out with
these guys
can you imagine the giant brass balls
you'd have to have to have a 77 so like
the murderer is actually sound like
clowns really yeah I mean naming their
house corpse would ya and and the road
that led up to it they called it dead
horse road because we're evidently when
they first went out there to look at the
property they found it to the property
so they named the so they named the road
after that it's not even a road it's
just like a dirt path so Avery Brock is
driving this [ __ ] black Jeep with
white Pentacles on the doors and in his
tiny little mind he thinks oh well maybe
this is kind of you know a conspicuous
vehicle right so I should probably get
another one so he pulls over at a rest
stop in Mississippi and he wakes up the
next morning him and Tony West because
they were both together and they find a
guy another guy sleeping in a car at
this rest stop so they hold the gun to
him and lead him out into the woods they
were gonna take his car and then Tony
West shoots that guy damn he was like a
navy lieutenant or something like that
so if they hadn't killed that third guy
yeah they became serial killers at that
point pretty much yeah I think you have
to kill three yeah but they're supposed
to be sexual motive that depends depends
on how the FBI wants to write classified
yeah
multiple murders yeah three killers yeah
Kirby Phillips Kirby's
was the name of the Navy lieutenant that
they killed just to take his car yeah
now the only how these dudes just want
to do petty [ __ ] like steal a car but
they'll kill somebody over it right so
dumb big difference in the penalties
yeah and a big difference in you know
like well you know I'm gonna I'm gonna
take this guy's $40 I can't live you
know you suck enough yeah if you're
gonna go out to these people's house who
have been nice to you and have given you
free wine and they'll let you hang out
at their house it's bad enough that you
want to rob them right but why I mean
even if you had just robbed them why
didn't you just rob them alone bothering
anybody right you'll eventually get
caught yes I won't do that much time for
those robberies the murder right stupid
yeah right seventeen-year-old dudes are
really not the sharpest knives in the
drawer same right so so Scudder and Odum
were actually not found for a couple of
days a friend of theirs came out to
corpse with manner like he was going to
tell them that a friend of theirs had
died ironically and went out there to
the house and found them dead it
actually didn't take very long the weird
thing is that the two is that Avery
Brock and Tony West didn't actually get
caught they both turned themselves in
which you know uh what I want to go home
because the way they kind of spun it
when Avery Brock went confessed to the
police he said quote all I can say is
they were Devils and I killed them
that's how I feel about it trying to
become a hero yeah and like I said at
his trial his defense attorney which I
know that's the defense attorney ja blah
blah blah they're trying to get their
clients off or whatever but that's kind
of how they tried to play it that these
two guys were like sexual predators and
they had put LSD in the wine and all of
a sudden which they tested the wine and
there was no elevator
whatever but you know they tried to make
it seem like that these were these
degenerate satanic cult motoring they
just used it they just used the oddities
of those two guys as justification for
problem that's exactly what they did and
it was kind of sad that because of the
Aryan because of the time like I said
this was 1982 this was satanic panic we
also did a show about rural yeah so you
know we grew up in places like that we
know yeah I love certain elements of the
south but yeah in those days you had to
be careful who was you were talking to
the older generations they were
wandering around in the early eighties
were backwards well and the sad thing
now in the shocking thing I mean I well
I was kind of shocked not that shocked
but a little bit shocked that even
nowadays like when I was researching
this show when I was reading different
blogs and stuff like that about it there
are still some whack jobs out there who
will comment on these things that these
two guys oh they kind of had it coming
yeah cuz they were Satanists and they
were gay and bla bla so obviously they
deserve getting shot in the face which I
don't even if they really even were safe
I just had that as a decorative motif
that's what I need and like some other
people have said you know it wasn't the
yeah they had some some devil stuff like
I think he had like a like a really
pretty one so did all the young iron
maiden fans exist so you know and see
the thing that bothers me is that you
know when I was growing up that's kind
of what my bedroom look like yeah I had
skulls everywhere posters and stuff like
that so like I deserve to be shot in the
face too awesome
you know I mean that's like a really
horrible exact my stepdad run in there
pull down my KK downing poster you know
I was in a new wave so he was over games
yeah pretty [ __ ]
yeah of course it's Renteria got more
[ __ ] than anybody's dudes all married
supermodels they did and it's like
everybody's like tease em for being gay
they're like yeah totally gay we're
stealing your girlfriend again one of
them was the biggest player yeah I'm
just kind of making the point that like
I said this was satanic panic era so I
almost kind of feel like if they hadn't
killed that other guy you know they
might have got I don't think they would
have gotten away with it but they might
have got a lighter sentence now as it
happened one of the [ __ ] every Brock
I think he got he attempted suicide in
jail because of course he did but he
didn't die unfortunately he he got three
want to be a tough guy till they kind of
behind bars I need yeah that's what I
mean was a shark yeah so he didn't even
he failed at that now he got three
consecutive life terms now the other one
Tony West who was the one that had shot
the Navy lieutenant he actually got the
death penalty at first but then it was
commuted to a life sentence later so
both of these scumbags are still in
prison they're both still alive they're
they're both still in pers I think in
Augusta so you know sadly dr. Scudder
was cremated and he was actually sent
back to Wisconsin where he was
originally from and buried his sister
requested he was there now Joey
Odom he was also cremated and his ashes
were scattered in the Rose Garden of
course way now like I said corpse with
Manor the ruins of it are still there
[Laughter]
but so since such a horrible thing
happened on this property and it's kind
of sad because I was kind of looking for
some documentaries about corpse wood
manner the only one I found that was
kind of worth a [ __ ] well that I thought
was worth the [ __ ] was called corpse
wood 1982 and this guy had uploaded he
said oh my mom made this back in the 80s
you know when the case was new and she
was from around that area so I start
watching it and I discover that the
woman that made this documentary had
let's call it an agenda and she very
much was a proponent of the fact that
these two guys that are coming because
they were gay in their Satanism blah
blah so after about 20 or 30 minutes I
was just like [ __ ] this lady and I
turned it off the only other
documentaries I could find about it were
paranormal ones like paranormal teams
going out there because now you know
everyone says now because this horrible
thing happened there you go out to
corpse wood and it's super creepy and
sometimes you can see or you can hear
gunshots which is probably just hunters
far away I'm sure or you can hear a harp
playing because doctors Fedder played
the harp he had a big old harp in the
house and you can also hear glass
breaking and things like that and some
people have also reported that they have
seen like glowing dog eyes which are
supposedly the ghost of one of the
couple's
dogs the dog was named oh my god go with
him go to some of the farms that I've
worked at because actually my family was
in the horse business for a long time
too English a question horses but in
some of these barns have goats
yeah and goats are hilarious they're so
awesome
they're very smart and they're a lot
like dogs yeah they'll follow you around
they do funny
absolutely hilarious and they eat
garbage
they'll eat anything which is nice
you thinking kind of clean up your yard
you got a wife then you turn around
there eat in the back your pant leg you
know they're trying to chew your pants
yeah they're just mess anyway so that
was this story of corpse wood and I
guess we're at the halfway point now so
we will take a break right now when we
come back I'm going to talk about the
wineville chicken coop murders which was
another request by another listener so
we'll be back in just a few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
hey 13 o'clock fans love the show but
don't have an hour to spare check out
our new list channel 13 o'clock in
minutes all the fun creepy topics of the
main podcast but in easy to swallow
bite-sized pieces
links in the description more videos to
come soon
[Music]
okay and we're back now if you guys saw
I don't know if you guys saw it I saw it
it came out in 2008 and it was a movie
called changeling and it was directed by
Clint Eastwood
and Angelina Jolie was in it now I don't
know if you guys know but this was based
on a real story which is nowadays
referred to as the wineville chicken
coop murders now the thing about the
wineville chicken coop is it's really
it's kind of like two stories in one
because you had kind of the thing that
the movie changeling focused on and then
you kind of had the serial killer angle
these two things are kind of related but
they're also kind of two weird stories
in their own right so basically the
story of changeling based on a true
story is based on the story of Christine
Collins and she had a nine-year-old son
named Walter now one day she gave Walter
some money and he was gonna go to see a
movie and he never came back
this was March 10th 1928 the LAPD
obviously she reported him missing the
LAPD began to look for him they looked
for him for months and months and they
weren't making any progress now around
this time in the late 1920s the LAPD
there had been a lot of scandals the
public were not really happy with them
so they were getting a lot of flack for
not being able to find Walter Collins so
about five months after the kid went
missing they find this kid in DeKalb
Illinois now at first the kid says my
name is Arthur Kent and the cops are
like okay where are you from blah blah
blah they start talking to him but then
after a while the kid says no
I'm actually Walter Collins so the cops
in Illinois contact the cops in LA and
say hey we found Walter Collins so
Christine Collins Walter's mother she is
super excited she's like yeah they found
my kid so she pays to have the kid flown
out to LA and they have like the LAPD
staged this big you know reunion or
whatever Chino to make them look good
and stuff like that now the kid shows up
at the reunion and she immediately says
that is not my kid dance right yeah and
here's where it gets weird the cops
basically said to her why don't you take
him home and quote unquote try him out
for a couple of weeks baby's like a
mother doesn't know what her own kid oh
the cops like yeah now I have seen
pictures of the two kids nice they do
kind of look alike but you can tell it's
a different kid so you know she says
okay whatever so she takes the kid back
to her house but the whole time she's
like this is my kid was earlier that she
took the kid this is just a different
time yeah well the whole time I mean she
had the kid in her house for a couple
weeks and that whole time she was
actually getting signed statements from
relatives and friends and stuff that
knew the kid that signed the thing that
said this is not Walter Collins she got
his dental records together this other
stuff so then she comes back to the
police for with the kids she says this
is not my kid and at this point the LAPD
what who was that kid I'm gonna tell you
okay okay okay
at this point the LAPD instead just
saying oh our bad alright they say to
Christine Collins you are delusional and
you're trying to make us look bad and
they code 12 to her and put her in a
psychiatric hospital urbis breakdown
yeah right so they put her in a
psychiatric hospital
now she's in there for a little while I
don't think it was like a super long
time but you know it was in there she
was in there a few weeks in the meantime
they interview the kid and the kid
admits I'm not Walter Collins yeah he's
like man has a lawsuit there well yeah
I'll get that sit there so this kid says
I'm not Walter Collins I'm actually
Arthur Hutchins jr. yeah he was a
runaway yeah and he had been hitchhiking
around the country for a few weeks and
stuff like that how old was he he was
910 now a ten-year-old he was a runaway
and could just hitchhike back in the day
yeah evidently he had got the idea to
impersonate Walter Collins when one of
the people that he was riding with said
hey you look just you look like that
missing kid yeah and the kid thinks to
himself hey that kids from LA right if I
pretend I'm that kid then I can go out
to LA and meet my very favorite actor
Tom Mix damn who was in all the cowboy
movies and stuff like that back then so
this kid it was all a ruse so he could
get to Hollywood is what this kid was
doing yeah okay and this port and the
birds this kid's parents well his
parents actually came well he evidently
he'd been having some family problems
yeah
so his stepmother actually came out to
California had to come out to California
pick him up and take him back home yeah
so if the sad thing I mean I know the
kids 9:00 and everything like that but
he really did not seem to give a single
[ __ ] about the mother about she's like
well she knew that I wasn't her kid so
you know I got what I want to blah blah
I mean I don't think he got to meet Tom
Mix or anything when he got to go into
LA right okay so obviously that was not
her kid right so what really didn't
happen to her kid
yeah and now here is the second most
horrible part of the story man yeah this
is the horrible part of the story
okay so later that year later in 1928
this was in September there was a woman
named Jesse Clarke in Canada and she had
grown worried about her brother Sandford
who was 15
her brother Sandford had gone out to
California to stay with his uncle who
was named Gordon Northcott
she goes out there to check on him now
while Gordon Northcott is otherwise
engaged somewhere else Sanford the
fifteen-year-old boy comes to his sister
and says Gordon has been molesting me
and beating me up and he's also killed
some kids hmm so Jessie the sister is
like okay well I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
back to Canada I'm gonna contact the
consulate I'm going to contact
immigration because because Gordon
offcut was originally a Canadian but he
lived in California for quite some time
she segment I'm gonna sort this [ __ ] out
so she goes back and contacts the
authorities the authorities raid the
home of Gordon Northcutt and his mother
which was in wineville which is not
called that anymore and they raised him
and his mother Sarah Louise raised
chickens on this farm okay so the
investigators they interviewed Sanford
Clark Sanford Clark told them that his
uncle had kidnapped him was molesting
him had beaten him and also that Gordon
Northcutt had made him watch as he
killed two boys who were brothers Nelson
and Lewis Winslow a boy that he thought
was Walter Collins and another boy who
was Mexican whose name he didn't know
and he said now this boy he had been
beheaded and the head was burned
mm-hmm and now this kind of tied in with
an unsolved murder that the LAPD knew
about because they had found like this
little headless 9 year old kids and this
weird [ __ ] was happening back in 1928
yeah so when they when investigators
raided the the wineville farm they
didn't find any body bodies but they
found a whole bunch of bone fragments
yeah and they found some axes with hair
and human blood on them and that was
like that how are we talking about what
the guy that did it yeah Northcutt he
was 21 at the time so he was a young guy
doing this and the creepy thing is that
his mom kind of what his mom knew yes
she's mom knew now what Gordon
Northcutt apparently did was that he
would go cruising for little boys and he
would you know kidnap them in his car
and he would bring them back to the
chicken coop and molest them now most of
the time she took them home mmm
sometimes he took them home evidently
but sometimes he would kill them they're
not really sure how many he killed
because like I said they dug around all
the farm and everything like that they
just found bone fragments and Sanford
Clark the nephew the kid he said well it
was probably more than that but what he
would do is he would go out to the
desert and burn the bodies like in
various places so they don't really know
how many people he killed but like the
other creepy thing too not only was the
mom involved but also Sanford Clark the
fifteen-year-old kid he said that the
mom and Gordon Northcott had made him
participate in the murders because the
mom said oh well if we all do it then
none of us can arkin and any other ones
I mean this is some [ __ ] up [ __ ] well
yeah so so what do you mean by
participate what do they mean by
participating in them well now what
Sanford Clark said now he was
specifically referring to the murder of
Walter Collins right now they didn't
find anything
belonging to Walter Collins on the farm
they did find some belongings of the two
brothers that had been kidnapped so they
know that the two of them were there
there is some debate over whether Walter
Collins was killed but Sanford Clark
said he was one of the kids now he says
that they took Walter Collins into the
chicken coop and that the mother Sarah
Louise said that they each had to hit
him on the head with the ax like one
time like they all had to do it Yeah
right and then he had to help them get
rid of the bodies hmm so some sick
people yeah they were [ __ ] out yes and
like I said when they eventually caught
Gordon Northcutt and his mother and they
stood trial now Gordon Gordon's mother
Sarah Louise she admitted to killing
Walter Collins hmm I don't think she
admitted the other ones but she she
basically said on the stand that she
would do anything to protect her son
Yeah right
so she did all this how'd she kill him
no well I thought was the wanted
right so you know Sarah Louise said that
she had actually dealt Walter Collins
the deathblow and that she had buried
him next to the chicken coop so she
confessed to that now she got life in
prison they didn't give her a death
sentence because she was a woman
Gordon Northcutt the main sicko he was
23 when he stood trial it was January
1929 now he was one of those people that
he had a bunch of defense attorneys but
then he fired all of these I can defend
myself he did admit that he had molested
young boys he said it was because he
loved them Michael Jackson defense oh
[Laughter]
yeah yeah and so like his mom testified
for him and then all this like [ __ ] up
family [ __ ] came out his mother said oh
I'm actually his grandmother because his
real mother is his sister or something
like there was some kind of incest going
on with his dad and like the DA I don't
know it was like some kind of [ __ ] up
[ __ ] like that I don't know if that's
true but that's what she said it was all
kind of raped going on with this family
and everything so there are all messed
up Sarah Louise wasn't really considered
a you know a reliable witness because
she would basically say anything now
Gordon Northcote
he only he went on trial not for the
murder of Walter Collins but he went on
trial for the the two brothers and for
the unidentified headless boy and he was
sent to prison he was sentenced to death
and he was hanged in 1930 yeah and the
stigma about the crime was so bad that
the town of wineville actually changed
their name later on because they didn't
want to be associated they changed it to
Mira Loma so uh but the house is still
there there's someone someone still
lives in it and stuff like that one of
the saddest things is that Christine
Collins Walter Collins mother she
refused to believe that her son was dead
I mean there she kind of knew but she
kind of held out hope they didn't find
the body no they didn't find his body so
it's possible he could have still been
alive because some people that
Northcutt evidently some boys that he
kidnapped and molested did get away or
or he let them go not the kid at masada
showed up that's what I figured but she
didn't want to really know and and the
sad thing too was that
Gordon Northcote before he was executed
he basically he sent Christine Collins a
telegram and he said if you come and
visit me before my execution I'll tell
you the truth like I'll tell you what
happened and stuff like that so she did
and then when she got there he's like oh
I'm innocent I don't know anything about
it and that's all he would say right I'm
like well [ __ ] right so she never
knew she never knew what happened to him
I mean I'm sure that Walter Collins was
probably one of the victims of this
[ __ ] you know but the fact that he
would never give her that satisfaction
that she would know so she really went
to her grave even maybe he's still alive
he was gonna say something that he
changed his mind yeah I'm like yeah he
sounds like a real [ __ ] piece of work
I'm just saying and it just it makes me
so sad that he did that like it's his
last [ __ ] act on you just decided he
was gonna [ __ ] with her and [ __ ] like
that
yes that yeah you mentioned Michael
Jackson yeah I always thought that
Michael Jackson did this [ __ ] you know
that he did that but you know what I saw
the program that got put together that
it's there's a possibility that he got
set up you think maybe we ought to do a
show about it one of these days maybe
and look into it there was a guy who
brought up some pretty cool ideas that
now it might have been a setup because
some of the people that first could
first accused him and then I couldn't be
trusted because they had a background to
extort people something like that I have
to go back and look at it is possible
and that in the media said that the kid
identified certain things about Michael
Jackson but if you actually look at the
details he didn't make the
identification there's all kinds of
little details that and that may be that
the accusation caused Michael Jackson to
be to go deeper into his little
psychosis and he killed himself through
drugs basically yeah that's about yeah I
suppose that's possible that it was head
severed with money yeah yeah there was
that's a conspiracy to shake down a
bunch of money out of him that ready and
company's record companies wanting
wanting that wanting the Beatles catalog
back then that crap that's the thing
it's like I'm not I'm not usually one to
believe it like conspiracy theories but
something like that this conspiracy
theory about that it could if people
maybe people listen and want to hear the
show like that you put in the comment
section I can't remember all the details
is just off the top of my head but I
remember hearing it going you know what
that sounds kind of possible but I don't
know I wasn't there you know I I kind of
I don't know I kind of leaned toward the
fact that probably he didn't that's it
you know but like you said yeah it's
possible that some people could have
started accusing him and then it just
made him crazy okay so like I said 2008
Clint Eastwood made a movie called
changeling that was about the wineville
chicken coop murders I saw it a long
time ago I remember it being good I
don't remember how much of the murders
they went into like I cuz I remember it
mostly focused on Christine Collins and
like her kind of struggle against people
just trying to fob this kid I wish that
I mean yeah the murder part is horrible
it's open can you imagine can you
imagine like having this kid Brad you
sit like your kid is missing it yeah
they're like here's your kid that's like
that's not my kid you know I mean like
you'd know your kid for [ __ ] sake yeah
that would be like if I got kidnapped
and somebody said hey yeah we found we
found and then they'd be like no take
her home Shire out yeah it's totally her
you're just trying to make us look bad
but yeah that was the whole kind of J
and they and they slammed her in the in
the psychiatric ward because you could
do that back then is someone if someone
was just saying stuff you didn't like
you just put you can't do that well I
guess you got again so anyway that'll do
it for this special edition true crime
twofer that's my birthday edition and
also the faceless villain is done
edition yeah so as always if you liked
the show then
remember to follow us on Twitter like us
on Facebook subscribe to our YouTube
channel yeah share with your friends
share with your friends don't forget
about patreon oh yes go to our patreon
page and become a patron and get all
kinds of neat extra stuff also on the
blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress com there is also a little
link there to PayPal if you would rather
just give a one-time donation rather
than a monthly donation you can do that
that's a cool shirt also go to
zazzle.com slash 13 o'clock and check
out our t-shirt so we still have a bunch
of those available and that'll do it for
this episode bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
you